hätte geht es um die hier angucken
pflänzchen genauer gesagt darum wie man
richtig schön kräftigen jungen
pflänzchen im haushalt und vorzieht
[Musik]
jetzt so anfang mitte april fällt der
startschuss für die gurken an sucht man
kann das auch später im jahr noch machen
wir sehen unsere gurken tatsächlich bis
mitte juni aus also noch richtig spät
bis in den sommer hinein um burgen in
unterschiedlichen alters stadien zu
haben die unterschiedlich anfällig für
den mehltau sind der früher oder später
eigentlich immer ein gerät die jungen
können ist immer so ein bisschen besser
ab also stattfinden wie unsere aus hat
aber jetzt kann man im haus schon mal
anfangen und die pflanzen die wir jetzt
vorziehen
die können dann mitte mai also nach den
eisheiligen nach draußen gepflanzt
werden vorher natürlich gut abhärten und
so weiter und ab mitte mai kann man dann
auch gurken nach draußen ins freiland
säen das machen wir auch super gerne und
wir aber bevor wir jetzt die samen in
die erde bringen sprechende erstmal über
die gurken sorten es gibt ja so viele
unterschiedliche sorten die man bauen
kann
der große unterschied ist natürlich
erstmal zwischen freiland und
gewächshaus anbau aber viele leute
glauben gar nicht wie toll man auch im
freiland also auch diejenigen von euch
die kein gewächshaus haben trotzdem noch
gurken anbauen kann also starten wir mit
dem freiland sorten und da kann ich euch
drei sorten wirklich wärmstens ans herz
legen dass es einmal die sorte margit
[ __ ] 76 komischer name so sieht sie aus
das ist eine salatgurke die aber schon
eine etwas festere haut hat also nicht
so wie die schlangengurken die man aus
dem supermarkt kennt ihr noch ein paar
staffeln also das ist schon eine etwas
festere gurke aber eine super leckere
und die wächst vor allem super gut auch
im freiland wenn ihr es lieber ein
bisschen salat gurke gold also weniger
stacheln und glattere schale die
vielleicht auch ein bisschen dünner ist
dann kann ich euch sehr sehr die sorte
tanja empfehlen da es jetzt leider kein
bild drauf aber das ist auch eine
richtig richtig tolle freiland sorte und
die liefern jedes jahr ab die beiden und
für diejenigen von euch die auch ein
paar saure gurken einlegen
dementieren oder einkochen da kann man
so viele mitmachen da probiert mal eine
einlegegurken aus die haben dass sie die
haben kleinere gurken die auch ein
bisschen stacheliger sind wie man super
gut für saure gurken verwenden kann und
da bauen wir ganz gerne die sollte vor
gebirgs trauben an die kann man auch
frisch essen also wenn man mal nicht zum
einlegen kommt ist das auch nicht so
dramatisch aber sie eignen sich eben
besser um saure gurken einzulegen und zu
fermentieren als andere sorten die dann
schnell reich werden und eigentlich zu
groß sind und so weiter die muss man
dann oft klein schneiden in kleinere
stücke aber dann werden sie so schnell
matschig und das passiert eben mit den
einlegegurken nicht solange man sie
rechtzeitig erntet aber einige von euch
werden ja wahrscheinlich auch ein
gewächshaus haben und da bauen wir eine
sorte an die rein weiblich ist das heißt
sie nur weibliche blüten bildet und dann
an diesen blüten eben ihre früchte trägt
dass es dann eben ein bisschen
ertragreicher da waren wir die sorte
helena an eine salatgurke eigentlich so
wie man sie aus dem supermarkt kennt das
wichtige ist nur wenn man eine rein
weibliche sorte an bord dass man dann
keine anderen gurken sollten im gleichen
gewächshaus andauert die vielleicht
gemischte blüten haben also wo auch
männliche blüten mit dran sind und auch
wenn die mal stress hat also wenn es mal
richtig heiß ist dies auch ein bisschen
hitzeempfindlich und wenn es mal trocken
ist im sommer dann kann es schon sein
dass sie auch mal männliche blüten
bildet das ist dann natürlich nicht so
toll wenn auch ein bisschen darauf
achten dass man andere sollten
vielleicht nicht direkt neben dem
gewächshaus an bord sondern ein bisschen
weiter weg so dass da nicht ihn wecken
rein und raus schweren und dann
womöglich noch den männlichen pollen an
die rein weiblichen blüten bringen
was die jetzt braucht sind natürlich
erstmal töpfchen
dafür nehmen wir große töpfchen denn
also zehn mal zehn zentimeter sind die
ungefähr denn guten haben ein bisschen
eine eigenheit im vergleich zu anderen
gemüsen die ja gerne in kleinere tapping
gesellt und dann wieder fit werden mögen
wurden das überhaupt nicht die möchten
nicht an ihren wurzeln herumgefummelt
bekommen die möchten von vornherein in
ihrem endgültigen tat vielen sitzen und
deswegen ziehen wir die in großen töpfen
vor auch wenn das bei der anzucht ein
bisschen mehr platz auf frist oder
kostet aber das ist einfach besser wenn
man die guten nicht so oft stört und die
dann kräftige heranwachsen können aber
nicht aus ried im sagen kommt am ende
auch ein pflänzchen raus und deswegen
sehe ich pro töpfchen zwei samen aus so
dass man auf jeden fall eine pflanze hat
die aufgeht und falls beide ausgehen
reist man halt die schwäche raus ich
weiß dass du wie du darüber total leid
aber so kann man eben sicher gehen dass
man dann auch in jedem köpfchen ein
pflänzchen vorfindet dass man dann
später nach draußen oder ins gewächshaus
pflanzen kann wenn wir euch ins ländchen
aufgehen die vielleicht ein bisschen
verkrüppelte keine blätter haben oder
die blätter sich einfach nicht so schön
entfalten wie bei den anderen dann
sortiert diese pflänzchen aus weil die
später einfach einen schlechteren ertrag
haben nicht so kräftig werden wie die
gesunden verwandten auch wenn es wehtut
ich weiß aber dass wollen sich
eigentlich nicht wirklich diese
pflänzchen dann groß zu ziehen sich um
die zu kümmern usw
weil man von denen einfach nicht so viel
ernte bekommen würde als anzucht
substrat kannst du entweder ganz schön
ausgereiften kompost verwenden den
nehmen wir für unsere jungen pflanzen
anzucht super gerne und der solange der
reif ist also schön fein krümelig keine
großen stücke mehr enthält gut
abgelagert ist ist das überhaupt kein
problem da selbst salat 1 zu sehen was
komme auch oft so kommentare reihe von
leuten die sich nicht vorstellen können
dass man den kompost einfach direkt
sachen aussehen kann aber das
funktioniert wunderbar oder du kaufst
dir anzuchterde die ist meistens ein
bisschen nährstoffarmer das heißt da
musst du wenn wir gleich über die
düngung sprechen einfach ein bisschen
mehr dünger in gießwasser geben so dass
du das wieder ausgleichen kannst damit
fest jetzt einfach deine
häppchen dann machst du ein loch das
ungefähr zwei zentimeter tief ist wer
das ist die seite für die gurken
bevorzugen legst du deine beiden samen
rein verschließt es wieder und gießt das
vorsichtigen in der weichen brause schön
an dass die erde feucht ist aber nicht
pitschnass und die samen auch boden
schluss haben das heißt dass die erde
schon überall um die samen drumrum
geschlemmt wird dass sie wirklich schön
kontakt mit der erde haben kannst auch
leicht andrücken wenn du deine samen
gesät hast und dann wissen die
gurkenpflanzen umziehen und zwar in
einen sehr warm ohr denn guten wollen
eine kein temperatur von ungefähr 24
grad
ich erreiche das immer in dem ich sie so
in die nähe der heizung stelle stellt
die töpfchen nicht auf die heizung weil
dann trocknen sie super schnell aus und
dann können da auch keine pflanzen
aufgehen aber das ist eben wichtig dass
man darauf achtet dass sie wirklich eine
schöne warme temperatur haben damit
überhaupt pflänzchen aus den samen
auskommen können und sobald sie
pflänzchen dann raus schon aus der erde
brauchen sie ist gar nicht mehr so warm
da reicht es so und die 16 18 grad
völlig aus ist sogar besser wenn jung
für uns ein bisschen kühler stehen als
bei normaler zimmertemperatur und sobald
sich die ersten blätter zeigen wollen
die wurden natürlich photosynthese
betreiben
die pflanzen brauchen ungefähr 16
stunden licht am tag das ist anfang
april noch ein bisschen schwierig dass
sie das einer fensterbank bekommen und
auch im mai und so weiter sind die
fensterbänke oft noch zu dunkel
die tage sind noch zu kurz und die
pflanzen bekommen nicht das licht was
sie brauchen um richtig schön kräftig zu
werden natürlich funktioniert das und
man kann sich da auch mit spiegeln
alufolie und so weiter aushelfen aber
wir arbeiten super gerne mit led
pflanzen lampen die hängen wir über den
pflanzen auf haben eine zeitschaltuhr
eingestellt so dass die auf 16 stunden
eingestellt ist geht morgens an wir
müssen uns um nichts kümmern geht abends
wieder aus so dass die pflanzen einfach
das licht bekommen in dem spektrum was
sie brauchen und ja es macht es einem
einfach viel leichter aber ich verstehe
auch gut wenn man die sich nicht
anschaffen kann ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt die ökologische variante sehe
ich genauso daher müssen die pflänzchen
dann jetzt also umziehen
sie brauchen es nicht mehr so warm und
dann kannst du nach ungefähr ja sagen
immer ein zwei wochen auch mit dem
düngen anfangen das geben wir über das
gießwasser beim gießen ist es ganz
sinnvoll wenn man immer in die unterlage
gehst so dass das wasser in die töpfchen
hoch steigen kann und man nicht von oben
ist weil dann weiß man nicht so genau
hat die pflanze jetzt genug ist es
vielleicht unten noch ganz trocken das
kann man von oben immer gar nicht so gut
sehen und wenn man einfach in die
unterlage wasser gießt dann bedienen die
pflanzen sich und alles ist genauso
befürchtet wie man das eben haben will
und in das gießwasser kannst du dann
auch den dinger rein gegen wir verwenden
dafür einen biologischen flüssigdünger
dem man einfach doppelt so stark
verdünnt wie auf der packung angegeben
denn die jungen pflanzen brauchen noch
nicht wirklich viel dünger aber es ist
schon ganz wichtig wir die pflanzen dass
sie auch schön kräftig wachsen können
dass man ab und zu ein bisschen ging
damit ins gießwasser gibt aber diese
pflanzen sollen nicht immer im wasser
stehen sondern ab und zu auch ein
bisschen austrocknen so dass sie lernen
dass sie sich selber ihr wasser in dem
job suchen müssen dass sie den kräftiges
wurzelwerk entwickeln und schon mal ein
bisschen daran gewöhnt werden dass sie
nicht immer alles so bekommen wie sie
das gerne hätten sondern eben auch ein
bisschen selbstständig werden und wenn
sie dann ins beet gepflanzt werden auch
nicht so abhängig davon sind dass man
jeden tag mit der gießkanne da
vorbeischaut vor dem haus tanzen
natürlich auch abhärten dazu habe ich
auf dem kanal in den letzten wochen ja
auch schon ganz viel gesprochen also
wenn ihr noch mal genau wissen wollt wie
das funktioniert zum beispiel mal im
garten arbeiten im frühlings video
vorbei da erzähle ich glaube ich
richtung ende des videos wie das
funktioniert also die pflänzchen nach
und nach draußen gewöhnen weil die
können einen sonnenbrand bekommen also
das ist wirklich krass wie dass die
pflanzen dann auch zurückwirft und wie
empfindlich die sind wenn die niemals
vorher in der sonne gestanden haben um
sich kurz der hand zu gewöhnen wenn sie
ins beet gepflanzt werden und nach den
eisheiligen könnt ihr sie dann raus
pflanzen die wechsel als gärtner unter
euch kennen sogar schon früher loslegen
man kann je nach wetter auch oft schon
im april die gurken ins gewächshaus
pflanzen ich werde auf jeden fall einen
guten pflanzt video machen wo ich auf
die freiland gurken und auf die
gewächshaus gurten eingehe so dass wir
unsere guten jetzt zusammen im haus
vorziehen können und dann rechtzeitig
auf dem kanal das video online geht um
sie nach draußen zu pflanzen ich werde
dann sicher auch noch mal in der saison
ein video über die pflege machen also
gerne den kanal abonnieren und auch die
glocke drücken wenn du informiert werden
möchtest sobald die neuen guten videos
erscheinen jetzt ist auch übrigens ein
toller zeitpunkt um zucchini kürbis und
die melonen aus zu sehen und auch gewinn
drücke auch entspannend finde ich die
kann man auch supergut einlegen also die
könnt ihr ganz genauso behandeln wie die
gurken auch da könnt ihr die anleitung
eins zu eins übertragen wenn du wissen
willst was du jetzt aussehen kannst dann
schau mal gerne da trieben vorbei
darüber habe ich nämlich letzten es auch
schon ein video gemacht also geh raus
und macht die welt ein bisschen grüner
wir sehen uns am samstag wieder biss
dann